fans were delighted to see patrick
stewart reprise his role as professor x
in the latest dr strange movie but there
was one easter egg that most viewers
missed here is the x-men tease and
doctor strange 2 only hardcore fans
noticed it's been a long time coming but
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is finally here the bold new
chapter of the marvel cinematic universe
pushes the master of the mystic arts
further than ever before as he's thrown
into different realities in his fight to
save america chavez from being killed by
a supernatural entity like many big
blockbusters of the last few years it
was met with production delays due to
the pandemic but the sequel finally
gives fans the live-action multiversal
adventure they've been looking for
thanks to chavez's powers steven strange
is a little wiser this time around
although he's mourning the life he could
have had with christine palmer who gets
married just as the adventure begins the
idea that there are alternate worlds
where he winds up being with christine
as a tantalizing idea for the sorcerer
and it's a sentiment scarlet witch
shares in this turn as the surprising
main villain wanda maksimov is looking
for a universe where she can be with her
sons billy and tommy after the events of
wandavision but the adventure across the
multiverse sees dr strange meet a
mysterious council of heroes who have
sworn to protect their universe and
beyond the illuminati fans already got a
glimpse of the team in the trailers
recognizing patrick stewart's voice and
the iconic yellow chair from the comics
and animated series we can now gladly
confirm he reprises his role as
professor x but there's another
surprising x-men tease in the scene and
this one only hardcore fans noticed it
was only a matter of time before we
started to get major x-men characters in
the mcu after disney bought fox back in
2019 as most fans will already know the
x-men and fantastic four franchises
exist in their own separate universes
although deadpool makes plenty of jokes
about marvel comics and the mcu with his
signature fourth wall breaking humor
let us go talk to the professor
mcavoy or stewart these timelines are so
confusing
although many expected marvel to simply
reboot the x-men to fit the mcu the
studio is clearly taking a slightly
different approach since patrick stewart
returns from the original movies to play
charles xavier again although this time
he's in the yellow hover chair
the illuminati will see you now
when the film first introduces the
illuminati it's an incredibly surprising
scene and professor x's late arrival
only adds to the spectacle especially
because the theme song from the original
x-men animated series heralds his debut
it's worth pointing out that this isn't
the first time we've seen an x-men star
show up in the mcu to reprise their role
evan peters returns his quicksilver in
wandavision although it's later revealed
as a fake out peters is actually a
normal man named ralph boner at least
professor x is actually who he says he
is here albeit a marginal multiversal
variant the theme song is a real treat
for hardcore fans and it comes with
another surprising detail buried in the
end credits when looking at the
multiverse of madness credits there's an
interesting detail in the music section
it lists the iconic theme music as x-men
97 theme this suggests that the upcoming
x-men 97 animated revival series will
use the original theme song when it
arrives on disney plus in the near
future it's entirely possible that x-men
97 is set to take place on the same
version of earth that the illuminati
live on in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness or they might
exist in their own version of reality
for now it's anyone's guess but the
multiverse does open up so many
possibilities for franchises that
weren't previously connected to the
ongoing tapestry of the mcu obviously
there's a fantastic four movie in
development at the moment but it's not
clear whether john krasinski will
reprise his role as reed richards from
the film or if it'll be someone
completely different the same can also
be said for patrick stewart and
professor x whenever marvel eventually
releases a proper x-men movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you